germany's energy regulator has
temporarily stopped the approval process
for the nordstrom 2 gas pipeline it says
the operating company of the
controversial pipeline between russia
and germany needs to comply with german
law
it is yet another setback for the 10
billion euro project which has been
dogged by delays both ukraine and the
united states have opposed it russian
president vladimir putin said last month
the country could quickly boost natural
gas supplies to the eu
and rob watts from dw business has been
looking into this story for us hi rob so
what is behind this decision to halt the
approval process you mentioned there
that the regulator doesn't see this
company nordstrom 2 a.g is complying
with german law and that's not to say
that it's doing something wrong but the
point is that this is a russian-backed
company majority shareholders are a gas
gazprom the german they're the russian
company that's based in switzerland
which means it doesn't have to comply
generally day to day with german law so
what the regulators in germany want to
happen
is for nordstrom 2 to be transferred to
a company that is compliant with german
law now there's two ways you can do that
you can convert the existing company to
a german company or you can do what the
company is planning to do which is to
set up a subsidiary based in germany and
the regulators have said okay that
should solve the problem but we're only
going to restart this certification
process once we're satisfied that that
has been fully completed that all the
right assets are in the right hands and
that the hr so that the staff of this
company are being run by a german-based
company what are the consequences of
this
well for russia and germany this is bad
news because germany really wants to
start getting some more supplies of gas
i mean the whole of europe is suffering
from a gas shortage at the moment
they're seeing energy prices
skyrocketing the russians of course want
to start selling their gas to germany as
well so it can make extra money and it's
said that the second that nordstrom 2 is
permitted to con to to open
it can double the amount of gas that
it's sending here in fact the pipeline's
already full of gas they just have to
turn the taps on but that's not going to
happen until approval happens so does
anyone actually stand to benefit from
having this delay well this is
a hugely controversial project and there
are plenty of people who are against it
and some very big names we're talking
about the united states that hates
nordstrom 2 because it thinks that its
allies in europe are going to be too
reliant on russian gas as a as a
consequence of it and also you've got
ukraine which stands to lose out a great
deal of money on what i call transit
fees from the the gas that currently
passes through ukraine on its way to
western europe because it's going to go
through the bolt again it's going to
bypass ukraine so though they don't
necessarily stand to benefit from this
delay they won't be shedding a tear over
it all right very interesting rob watts
from dw business thank you very much for
bringing us that story